- So we need to get into
something very important though.
So a few weeks back, you
tweeted. Years back, not weeks.
Years back, she tweeted this.
Guys, I hate to tell you
this, but red wine is gross.
And I came back to you online
and was like #Blasphemy.
I mean, maybe you haven't had
the right glass of Pinot Noir
is all I'm saying.
Have you changed your mind?
Do you like wine at all now?
- I like it.
I'm trying to like get cooler
with reds, but I'm just like.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- A white girl.
- It can be a real.
No, okay, well, I'd like
to change your mind.
- So I just.
- [Maren] Okay.
- I just, Justin, here he's coming. Okay.
- [Howie] Oh wow!
- [Maren] Oh, my goodness.
- So I just wanna have a chance.
- Justin!
- I wanna have a chance.
Look at this, check this out.
Now what are we? I'm
very excited about that,
what are we letting her taste?
- We are having a 2019
Kosta Browne Pinot Noir
from Duckhorn.
It has enticing aromas of
fresh blueberry, blackberry,
and lilacs that envelop the senses,
a layered acidity and
a long powerful finish.
- [Kelly] Ooh!
- [Howie] Wow!
- I like the words.
- Okay.
- In one ear, out the other.
- Doesn't it sound like he
knows what he's talking about?
- Literally.
- He sounds like he
knows what he's reading.
- Will it get me drunk?
- No, yes!
- Okay, that's all I really care about.
- I mean, people have told
me. Just shake it around.
- Can I have the peanuts?
Can I have the peanuts?
- Okay. Oh my God, for a
minute, I was like, wait, what?
- Peanuts noir.
- I was like, sir?
- Thank you.
- Okay, wait, taste your,
taste it. Just, I'm just.
- [Maren] You sniff it right?
- [Kelly] Make sure you sniff it first.
Like smell it as you.
- Like, what do I do?
- It's opened. It's opened.
- Okay.
- We've opened it for you.
- [Howie] Wow.
- Mmm!
- You're lying. Are you lying?
- Okay. This is the only
kind of red wine I can drink
is like, pinot noirs,
because they're not gritty.
- [Kelly] Yeah! That's why I like 'em.
- Yeah, I mean they'll
make your teeth purple.
- They're not like too earthy.
They do make your teeth purple!
- And there's a hint. Isn't
there a hint of, what was there?
- [Kelly] Blueberry.
- Right.
- [Kelly] Blueberry
- [Maren] Some lilac.
- Yeah.
- And some lilac.
- Right.
- Yeah, I love those like
sommelier explanations when they,
especially red wine, they
get so all about themselves.
- With a hint of.
- They're like, mm, tennis
balls. It's tennis balls.